turning to politics the final run-up of
to the November elections traditionally
begins on Labor Day so we've officially
entered busy season for political
correspondence President Biden will
visit Pittsburgh and Milwaukee today
campaigning for local candidates Mr
Biden and former president Donald Trump
have been busy rallying their voters
each accusing the other of threatening
America's future
Scott McFarland is at the White House
for us this morning Scott what can we
expect from the president's trip hey Ed
good morning President Biden will spend
this Labor Day rallying labor with
speeches before major unions in those
two states with particularly pivotal
competitive Statewide elections
Wisconsin and Pennsylvania and he won't
be the only one out of campaigning
neither has his name on the ballot this
November but President Biden and his
predecessor for making their cases on
the campaign Trail today after a speech
in Milwaukee the president travels to
Pittsburgh his third visit to
Pennsylvania in less than a week
underscoring the stakes of Elections
there equality and democracy are under
assault it comes after a fiery speech in
Philadelphia last Thursday Donald Trump
and the mega Republicans
represented extremism that threatens the
very foundations of our Republic over
the weekend Republicans accused the
president of giving a divisive political
speech if this was a speech to unify the
American people had just the opposite
effect it basically condemned all
Republicans who supported Donald Trump
the White House said the criticism was
only directed at those who've incited
violence and continue to deny the 2020
election results he is calling on
Democrats Independence mainstream
Republicans to really come together and
make that decision and stand together to
make their voices heard so that we can
protect what is the most important to
our value as a country he's an enemy of
the state you want to know the truth on
Saturday former president Trump also in
Pennsylvania fired back they're trying
to silence me and more importantly the
trying to
Choose You appearing side by side with
the Republican candidates in the state's
U.S Senate and gubernatorial races Trump
spent a sizable chunk of his almost
two-hour speech focused on the FBI
search of his Mar-A-Lago Resort trying
to fire up his base the FBI and the
justice department have become vicious
monsters controlled by radical left
scoundrels the justice department and
Trump's legal defense are awaiting the
ruling from the federal judge in Florida
about whether to order that special
master that independent third party to
review the record seized from Mar-A-Lago
no certainty on when that ruling is
going to come and no certainty on how or
when it'll impact the midterm elections
which are now just 64 days away Ed
64 beautiful days Scott McFarland thank
you we'll be there for all of us